fragen fragen fragen fragen fragen in
die kommentare schreiben alle fragen die
ich einfallen und die ihr gerne
beantwortet hätte in die kommentare
damit wird es glaube ich eine richtig
geile special du versuchst es auch immer
wieder alter du kannst mich nicht hätten
nein einfach richtig noch einmal
davos es geht so herzlich willkommen zu
einer ganz besonderen bundesweite games
besonders unter anderem auch weil
reitplätzen wird weil er max clifford es
geht los
hallo das geht aber jetzt sag mal hallo
zu sks abonnenten chili und wie sich
bekommst du dann und wie viel du kommst
du dann gut also dass das dürft ihr auch
klar dass du denn angst und the scales
bin ich dass mir nicht oft auf fakt als
kleidern schreiben wir später noch mal
ok ich muss jetzt nur noch über piepen
ihr wahrscheinlich nicht irgendwie
gehört haben weil er weiss natürlich
nicht bedacht hat dass er vielleicht
gerade nicht helfen sollte wo du wohnst
du bist in amstetten aber jeden fall
könntest du mal kurz erklären wieso es
gab eine ahnung von der welt kam
es gehört mir gesagt so hey hey my fire
ich ohne normal und ich halte auch und
so und ich würde mir wünschen dass immer
beide eine aufnahme sei es ist ja der
dvd wir angesprochen haben
genau dieses wochenende am samstag in
berlin und der weiche sind ja ganz gute
kumpels und dann pferde einfach bei mir
vorbei fand einmal bei mir wir machen
ein paar videos zusammen und dann am
nächsten tag fahren also morgen am
freitag haben wir oder ich weiß nicht an
was an welchem tag das hoch ist auf
jeden fall am freitag fahren wir am leib
bei mir nach verbüßter nein ich lasse
jetzt das video kommt noch heute am bau
oder steak mit jemand und morgen freitag
ist der die wieder in berlin treffen
sich alle oder fast alle youtuber aus
dem die move netzwerk zudem unternahm
ich gehöre dazu
revier und pilz der der europa tritt und
sonst noch einige dm unter anderem für
die leute die dennoch kennen und ja da
könnte ich rein theoretisch auch mein
block machen
falls ihr bock habt auf einen die videos
anschaut was genau jetzt in die
kommentare
und lasst es mich wissen dann kann nicht
da war es für euch klar machten ja ich
werde die ganze tag von dem turbo abis
duo ich ich habe ihn einfach so weg als
ich habe eine angel wenn ich dich hab
nur eine angel und die ersten stein bist
du ich lauf geradezu dir alles zu der
einen falle da die man sowohl coop ist
er leiter richtung natürlich wieder her
geht einfach nicht auf michael du wirst
du wird häufig und gerne matic vom
richtigen richtig richtig übten aber ich
konnte dir kommt zu dir ich habe auch
nichts 20.000 wenn wir diese runde noch
gewinnen halter gelaufen lauf gerade aus
rund club geradeauslauf rechts was hatte
ich druck die reinholz axt zack die
beiden sollen jetzt kämpfen diesen
kämpfen ja wahrscheinlich die kämpfe
fast egal warte warte sgl hatte hoff hat
hier drei herzlicher preis ja ich hab
den ersten lauf live blog ich hab heut
ring eingesetzt und jetzt kriegt er
jetzt kriegst du junge jahr kommt jetzt
kriegst du deine ich habe keine
feierlich den maristen durch den besten
können auf jeden fall auf jeden fall
hatte der eigentliche grund für dieses
video ist der dass wir 5000 abonnenten
geknackt haben
im 5000 s kids um mich versammeln 5000
geile hengste und auf 98 8 kiss und
lediglich um klatscht in watte richtige
klatsche warte warte warte ich hab zwei
herzen gibt immer frist ihr gar nicht
mein bruder nicht mal nicht mein bruder
du [ __ ]
für alle die die harry potter referenz
verstanden haben schreibt in die
kommentare
und genau jetzt immer einem thema das
war eine richtige action runde bisher
jetzt können wir kurz durchatmen und
sagen worum es geht 5000 abonnenten und
habe ich mir ihr habt wirklich ein
special verdient dafür dass ihr mich
sehr so tatkräftig unterstützt hat und
so viele leute meine videos schauen bin
ich sehr dankbar führen deswegen habe
ich überlegt wir machen ein 50 fragen
special 5000 abonnenten 50 fragen klingt
zumindest halbwegs flüssig warum boxen
keine ahnung auf jeden fall leute was es
wichtigste ist schreibt genau jetzt eure
fragen in die kommentare
die ihr schon immer mal stellen wollte
fragen zu bezüglich meiner person
bezüglich youtube bezüglich privat wie
ihr bock habt ich zieh mal den helm auf
und macht einfach wie ihr lust habt
schreibt aber richtig richtig viele
fragen in die kommentare
ich will mal so 200 300 fragen sind das
haben wir mit den kommentaren damals
schon geschafft für alle die sich daran
noch erinnern ich will jetzt dass wir
fragen auch schaffen und ich glaube das
kriegen wir hin wollen ihn einfach sei
die recht mehr gewonnen jetzt ja genau
das hab ich auch positiv 5000 nicht
erreicht schreibt einfach so viele
fragen sinnvolle fragen zu meiner person
oder erfahrungen die ich allgemein auf
dem herzen liegen die was mit mir zu tun
haben in die kommentare
und ich hätte mir 50 raussuchen und dann
ein video machen vielleicht aus berlin
was auch ganz lustig eigentlich könnte
mir dieser außer mit 0 11 oder whatever
die frage aufstellen so showmaster mäßig
wir gehen auf die [ __ ] die eskalation
nicht mehr weg gemacht hat stehen
er hat ein eisen schwert lass dir
hinterher gehen der schon an
hauptsache ich werde nicht sehr gut
ich brauche ich brauche nicht mehr viele
hits für den hatte ich ja ich habe ein
perfekt junge was dir einfach fürs
abnehmen
aber nicht ernst aber dann gehen wir nur
die hälfte der fälle jetzt noch ein
fremdes tier habe ich schon habe ich bin
noch ein laster dann die jungen wie wir
aber die runde gerissener alle am anfang
ich hatte ja ich hatte ich hatte der
angel und du nur holz sind wir haben
einen typen der fast pleite war gefegt
richtig losgeht
wir sind euroskills am helfen die dicken
equipment sachen am brocken uhr jetzt
geht die global bobic
kommerziell ist er hier rechts rechts
ist vielleicht sprint ich auch einfach
mal so ich hätte ihn nicht den dialekt
electric works
ich gebe den andern wie gesagt hat ich
kann mir gut vorstellen das hier ein
paar menschen so die ein oder andere
frage haben ich wurde letztens auch
vermehrt gefragt ja es kelly besser
überhaupt auf den namen gekommen
ich glaube da gibt es schon ein paar
sachen die ich erzählen könnte und
deswegen einfach fragen fragen fragen
fragen fragen in die kommentare
schreiben alle fragen die ich einfallen
und die ihr gerne beantwortet hätte in
die kommentare damit wird es glaube ich
eine richtig geile special ja also wir
können auf jeden fall auch mal wieder
wenn du dann irgendwann mal wieder
vorbei schoss hier bei mir zu hause
dann können wir auch gern mal wieder in
lässigen stream machen ich hab so bock
ich habe auch meinen abonnent post
gesagt dass es in diesem sommer einiges
teams geben wird und woher die wird es
geben und zwar von taxis rechner
da müssen wir nicht mit ihm verscherzen
wenn das jetzt nicht kennen aber jolo
ich gebe einfach mein eisen schwert ja
ja genau das ist das relativ ich hab mir
wir haben eigentlich ich hab mir fehlen
zwei rüstungs funktionieren er ist voll
da hab ich ein bisschen tnt
ich hab keinen fall mehr hast du ja aber
ich weiß nicht ob ich zu geben soll muss
wahrscheinlich ein besseres schwert
nicht
dort macht
ok also also alles was die tnt alles was
wir haben alles
die leiter würde ich echt nicht so der
fan von okay wir machen
3 und er fällt 111 gefragt natürlich
macht er jetzt wieder die action am
brocken
die culex jetzt macht natürlich auch du
hast ein power bogen bestimmt ist und
was hatte ich habe im zweiten jahr 2000
kurz hab ich ja okay dann muss jetzt er
die action im stadtgebiet zwei feldern
der jubilar alte hat egal ob tnt sehr
gut sehr gut gespielt gut
der junge junge zwei herzen
ja ja ich stehe bitte nein ich hab nur
noch vier nicht im ernst eine verteilen
danke für 420 sekunden
nein nein du versuchst es auch immer
wieder alter du kannst dich nicht hinten
sowie viele sie alte geilste endkampf
alle gott war das alter [ __ ] my life das
war der krassesten kräftig jemals hatte
also richtig spaß gemacht
auf jeden fall sorge ich würde sagen das
video hat garantiert gefallen das war
richtig gut besucht war alles drin von
vor ein platzen von weiter das alles
einfach ich glaube ich die beste auf
nämlich bisher hatte auf youtube geilo
ich hoffe ich habe vieles können wieder
leute lasst einen like darin ist
gefallen hat cakmak subbass in der
beschreibung wie gesagt ganz wichtig
fragen die kommentare schreiben richtig
richtig viel
ansehen und dann will ich sagen haut
rein macht es gut und showbiz